- [Man] On 9/11 people
said here's our opportunity
to help, even though
we knew nobody by name,
they were all strangers
when they came to Canada.
How the community came together,
it was an amazing feat.
(uplifting music)
- [Narrator] In the moments
after the September 11th
terrorist attacks, United
States airspace was closed.
Hundreds of inbound flights
needed a safe place to land.
One of those places was
Gander, Newfoundland.
- Once you get halfway across the ocean,
the closest airport is Gander.
And at that day, they were told to land
at the nearest airport.
And 38 aircraft was nearer to Gander
than they were any other airport.
- I get this call, "Get out
in back of the airport."
So I go up there, and I'm just in awe.
I watched this big jet come in.
And I look again, and
there's lights of another one.
I go oh God.
- The night the planes landed here,
I was at the Legion, and the first thing
come out of my mouth was
thank God they're coming here,
'cause I know they're
gonna be looked after.
Not saying they wouldn't
be looked after elsewhere,
but I knew they would
be looked after here.
- [Narrator] Nearly 7000 shaken
and disoriented passengers
arrived in Gander, almost
doubling the population
of the tiny Canadian town.
- A plan of action went
into place, just like that.
And that's what the whole
community became involved with.
- I don't know of anybody
who didn't do something,
be it, you know, something
big or something small.
Everybody seemed to have done something,
because you knew it had to be done.
- [Narrator] All across Gander,
people opened their doors
to stranded passengers,
including over 700 at
a local primary school.
- The teachers went home that day
and emptied out their linen closet,
took every blanket and pillow
that was not on the bed,
and they brought it back to the school.
By early morning,
maybe 5 or 6 o'clock,
we had had four flights
arrive at Gander Academy.
We kinda went on adrenaline.
I know I didn't go home and
sleep until 72 hours later.
It just went on for days.
And everything that we
needed seemed to come.
And I still don't know how that happened.
- This is one from a schoolteacher
in Montclair, New Jersey.
He sent me that on the first anniversary.
People invited them into their homes,
gave them keys to their
cars, the keys to their home,
and never blinked twice about it.
- [Narrator] The generosity
of the people of Gander
was a bright spot on one of
the world's darkest days.
- When it was all over,
I was never more prouder
that the greatest strength
we have is our people.
And we have great people here in Gander.